bertrand alain perreault sont dans la
même chose c'est une journée bien
spéciale aussi à celle des maris relais
à montréal via l'établissement accueille
aujourd'hui quatre bénévoles qui
participent au projet sony actions de la
fondation sunny dee extrême l'objectif
est bien simple permettre à des
adolescents de partager quelques heures
par semaine avec des personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie
à les voir jouer et au programme
aujourd'hui un exercice de motricité
fier quand voulant 6 6 et 5 kw est bon
de gagner là-dedans les personnes âgées
reçoivent mais je pense les jaunards
soit aussi apprendre des choses puis
apprennent surtout la vie qu'est ce que
c'est de vieillesse ou parce qu'ils sont
un plus pour les autres ça va faire des
meilleurs êtres humains
c'est à la suite de la mort de son fils
sonny âgé de 14 ans khaled et bien a
décidé de créer sa fondation
dix ans plus tard sa mémoire est honorée
par la centaine de bénévoles qui
participent au projet des jardins c'est
nouveau ça ni un fait que pour moi c'est
ça me fâche au 15 août un bon
automatiquement quand ils rentrent les
jeunes quand tu arrives sur laitages on
le voit ce regain d'énergie
on voit que les ai beau sourire on voit
que les personnages y sont contents de
voir ils veulent l'eau mais ils veulent
leur touche et a été capable dans ta
journée de donner le sourire à quelqu'un
d'une quelconque façon je trouve que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de bien
pire un sentiment de gratitude à la fin
de la journée ici c'est le fun quatre
fois c'est mes camions gm s'enfonce vers
heures pour de vrai c'est quand même
somme après spa raison je les trouve
activités ils sont portés ils font tout
leur possible
oui je trouve ça beau le projet a reçu
dernièrement une subvention de 1,7
million de dollars sur quatre ans du
gouvernement du québec
l'objectif est de faire participer
l'ensemble des chs élevé de la province
afin d'aider à briser l'isolément et les
préjugés et surtout d'amener les jeunes
à côtoyer davantage de personnes âgées
ils nombreux parents lisaient pas pour
tout le temps ils sont avec nous pour un
temps limité
je pense que le temps qu'ils sont les il
faut profiter d'eux parce que c'est des
personnes qui vont beaucoup nous
apprendre ici marie michel lauzon
radio-canada à montréal